don't worry saki's heading out of the
administration but there are good people
there are good people at the
administration there are smart people
that she can leave this up to
um like kamala harris right she's she is
this woman i mean you talk about people
that are on the ball that know what
they're doing you look at her like you
if you if you were putting in the
dictionary like
smart they're going to show you a
picture of kamalas here she is back in
july of 2021 uh because if you think the
woke-ism thing isn't going to stop
they've been ushering in this for a long
long time and and when you figure it out
you realize that they're the racists
they're the ones that hate middle
america and everything else they they
look down on all of us and here's kamala
you may remember this one from uh about
eight months ago
talking about people in middle america
is agreeing to voter id one of those
compromises that you'd support i don't
think that we should
underestimate
what that could mean
because in some people's mind that means
well you're going to have to
um
xerox or
photocopy your id to send it in to prove
you are who you are well there are a
whole lot of people especially people
who live in rural communities who don't
there's no kinko's there's no office max
near them
people have to understand that when
we're talking about voter id laws
be clear about who you have in mind and
what would be required of them to prove
who they are
of course people have to prove who they
are
but not in a way that makes it them it
almost impossible for them to prove who
they are
it's just so extraordinary like you just
have to laugh the stupidity first off
when she says of course people have to
prove who they are did she just come out
as for identification because that's
racist according to her own party um
also this idea that people in the middle
of the country they can't get to a
kinkos what are these
effing morons there's no kinkos or
officemax near them they don't have
printers they don't have a 99 hewlett
packard printer that has a thing and you
can lift it and put your id on it and
scan it these people are complete
warrants what's hilarious about this is
these are the same people
who think that black people are too
stupid to be able to get an id so they
hate middle american people because they
can't get to a kinkos or don't know how
to use a printer and they also think
that black people who live in the inner
city are too stupid to figure out how to
get an id they hate all of us they
really do hate all of us you know we'll
do this will be a fun little thing to do
if if you're living in middle america
and uh you've got a printer
could you take a picture of your printer
tweet it at me and i'll retweet some
printers or other devices that you might
do you have a photocopy machine an old
school xerox that people used to sit on
to xerox their butt do you have one of
those send me some pictures very
exciting and i'd like and maybe i'll tag
kamala because she needs to know
that they're out there
you